c'est trop souvent les actrices de 40
ans qui jouent les quinquagénaires
tu as raison 40 ans
de la République en exercice absolument
Julie Gayet Julie Gayet
Julie Gayet qui répond cache sur les
années qui passent et elle dit c'est
trop souvent les actrices de 40 ans qui
jouent les quinquagénaires je n'ai pas
vérifié sur l'écran de contrôle si les
lumières me mettent en valeur je
m'attache avant tout à l'énergie du
personnage 50 ans c'est un âge dédicace
chez une femme avec l'arrivée de la
ménopause en gros à partir de 40 ans
elle joue des femmes de 50 et après
c'est fini ou comme disait Miou-Miou tu
vas jouer une grand-mère mais c'est
terminé bah pardon je trouve que c'est
vrai
regardez les plus belles actrices skate
Blanchette giulian Moore katwinslet
que j'adore et qui est très sympa de
Michael younbe les mecs sont étudiants
quand c'est des mecs qui jouent et sont
étudiants alors qu'ils ont 50 ans non
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai ah
non mais je promets que c'est
franchement je mets de leur côté les
filles mieux en parler mieux c'est quand
même assez et tout elle te dit
aujourd'hui soit on m'appelle pour être
grand-mère soit c'est fini il y a rien
d'autre il y a un seul exemple c'est
Meryl Streep on est bon le réservé
terminé 3 kilos mais Ryan qui était
magnifique tu crois qu'elle aurait des
lèvres comme ça à Neuilly proposer du
boulot il y a des très beaux rôles avec
Nicole Garcia par exemple avec Fanny
ardente
elle le disent aussi donc
c'est pas une actrice elle a fait une
série mais tu plaisantes elle est belle
c'est pas c'est pas une actrice quoi et
puis c'est la femme de François et elle
a quand même de quoi ça rattraper oui
elle a pas besoin de tourner mais
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive toi tu es méchant
pénal on a inversé 2000 tu vois tu es
devenu Mathieu
et l'amour là dans tout ça elle est
peut-être amoureuse
de couple le long de guerre bah voilà
absolument